will smith is offering a public apology
to chris rock saying in part quote my
behavior at last night's academy awards
was unacceptable and inexcusable
oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith
sharing a lengthy message to instagram
the king richard starr expresses regret
for striking chris following the
comedian's joke about wife jada pinkett
smith
jaina i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait
to see it all right
will explains quote jokes at my expense
are part of the job but a joke about
jada's medical condition was too much
for me to bear and i reacted emotionally
then he addresses chris directly quote i
would like to publicly apologize to you
chris i was out of line and i was wrong
i'm embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be
there is no place for violence in a
world of love and kindness
later in the ceremony will nabbed his
first oscar trophy for playing venus and
serena williams father and king richard
i think you might just have the next
michael jordan
oh no brother man
i guess me the next two his message
continues quote i would like to
apologize to the williams family and my
king richard family i deeply regret that
my behavior has stained what has been an
otherwise gorgeous journey for all of us
leading up to will's statement richard
williams who will portrays in the biopic
spoke out against the altercation in a
statement to e.t via richard's son the
former tennis coach says in part quote
we don't condone anyone hitting anyone
else unless it's in self-defense
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees and that's will apologizing to
the academy in his acceptance speech
which he reiterates in the message
i think that the um
[Music]
i think that the two gentlemen need to
deal with it and i think that the
academy needs to deal with it also on
monday the academy says an investigation
is underway announcing in a statement
quote we have officially started a
formal review around the incident and
will explore further action and
consequences
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay as for chris e.t is
learning new details about the rest of
his night while having fun at a
high-profile oscars after-party a source
tells e.t quote he didn't want to let
the incident with will ruin his night
out with friends chris was still in
shock by the whole incident and didn't
want it to become a whole thing at the
party so he didn't talk too much about
it
meanwhile will post it up at the
star-studded vanity fair bash seen here
breaking into song oscar in hand
[Music]
[Applause]
following the shocking on-air moment
reactions were mixed among celebrities
you know
i would like to more of a straight
apology
to chris i thought will's performance
was amazing and i'm sorry that he
tarnished it with his behavior i seen a
man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
they put her face up on the screen
looked over at his wife she was hurt
you